bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france comment votre cliente at elle été
averti de cet espionnage
elle a été à bercy par les journalistes
qui font partie de ce consortium et qui
ont eu ces informations elle est ce
qu'elle a été contactée depuis par les
autorités depuis les révélations par ce
collectif de journalistes pour faire la
lumière sur la faire on l'a appris ce
matin comme une enquête a été ouverte à
paris et une enquête qui va est ouverte
mais il ya également des plaintes qui
ont été déposées et dominique simonnot
va également déposer plainte et on va se
constituer partie civile afin d'obtenir
le maximum d'éléments et de comprendre
comment ça a fonctionné avec quel accord
et qui autorise ce type de d'espionnage
et quelles informations avez vous
aujourd'hui est ce que vous avez une
idée du cadre dans lequel dominique
simonnot à etel a été espionné et ce
qu'on sait un parent qui pendant combien
de temps
alors ces informations en les a pas de
manière certaine
on a des informations qui émanent des
enquêteurs et notamment des journalistes
enquêteurs qui ont indiqué à dominique
simonnot que c'est vraisemblablement le
maroc du fait qu'elle à l'époque il faut
quand même rappeler qu'elle n'a été
espionnées qu'en tant que journaliste du
canard enchaîné pas du tout dans le
cadre de ses fonctions actuelles mais
que ça serait dans le cadre de deux
sujets qu'elle traitait lorsqu'elle a
été journaliste au canard enchaîné et
des sujets qui déplaisait à la monarchie
marocaine
ces révélations ont étonné bas ce qui
est le plus étonnant c'est que si
dominique simonnot qui est une grande
journaliste mais qui n'est pas une
journaliste d'investigation
c'est une chronique judiciaire
si dominique simonnot et espionné ça
signifie que quasiment tous les
journalistes important dans toutes les
rédactions de france met d'ailleurs le
sont également
c'est ça qui est qui et qui est sympa
c'est à dire que si le convoi les
avocats qui ont été écoutés on peut se
dire que ben 500 avocats francs
c'est qu'ils ont des affaires dites mais
d'éthique ou importante le sont
également
mais c'est à dire que c'est parce que
comme l'a si bien rappelé votre sujet
c'est pas une simple écoute c qui
siphonnent l'intégralité des
informations qui sont sur le sma donc il
ya une violation des non seulement des
droits fondamentaux mais de ce qui est
plus important la confidentialité en ce
qui concerne les journalistes
c'est le secret des sources en ce qui
concerne les avocats se sont bien
évidemment le secret professionnel mais
pensez également aux médecins pour
qu'ils écoutent tout le monde et c'est
extrêmement grave parce que ça se fait
quand même avec l'accord et à la demande
de certaines de certains états là on
parle de l'engrais on parle de l'inde on
parle du mexique en parle du maroc
mais il faut quand même rappeler que l
eso l'entreprise américaine a indiqué
que avant toute demande deux ans de mise
à disposition de solo sicième à chaque
fois avant toute demande de livraison de
100 logicielle dit pegasus
elle attend un accord préalable les
autorités israéliennes dire que les
autorités israéliennes et savent
exactement quels l'utilisation qui est
écouté et par qui vous vous rendez
compte c'est extrêmement bas mais si
elle est l'état israëlien le fait vous
pouvez être certain que l'état américain
et les autres états le font également
qui on est et qui sont on peut pointer
du doigt aujourd'hui on retrouve
l'azerbaïdjan le rwanda avec 6 qu'est ce
qui selon vous la france peut jusque-là
n'avoir pas eu connaissance de
l'existence de ce logiciel d'espionnage
bien évidemment non ce logiciel
d'espionnage est connu et il est vantée
puisqu'on peut l'acheter
l'entreprise israélienne et ce aux gars
des dizaines de millions de tonnes grâce
à ce logiciel la sphère caso di avait
déjà révélé l'existence de ce logiciel
la faire de cette maison puisque je
rappelle que dix ans a été victime
également de celle ci vous dire la
puissance et l'intelligence de ce
logiciel vous avez l'homme le plus riche
du monde
qui a l'une des entreprises les plus
importantes du monde pensez bien qu'il a
mille et un conseiller qui veille à sa
cyber sécurité même lui a été victime de
ce logiciel donc c'est vraiment quelque
chose qu'on peut découvrir un posteriori
des années plus tard ou via des lanceurs
d alerte mais c'est la preuve qu'il faut
absolument que les états comme l'a très
bien expliqué édouard snowdon non
interview reprise par vos confrères de
france info
il faut absolument que les états
notamment l'état français via le
gouvernement s'engage et impose à des
pays comme un pays comme israël ou les
états unis à ne pas faire usage
veillez à ce que jamais on puisse faire
usage de ses logiciels à l'encontre de
des citoyens français
à défaut et s'exposent à des sanctions
je crois que vous êtes bien placé france
pour savoir qu'à partir du moment où il
ya des règles démocratiques qui ne sont
pas respectés ou qui sont considérés
comme n'étant pas respecté par certains
pays l'état français l'union européenne
états unis n'hésitent pas à prendre des
sanctions contre le pays qui est visé
et je pense par exemple avec ce qui
s'est passé contre la russie donc là on
pourrait quand même avoir des
engagements fermes une position
extrêmement faible puisque c'est ce qui
est le plus important parle de la
liberté de la presse en parle de du
secret professionnel des avocats
on parle du secret médical
il faut qu'on puisse que l'état français
puissent garantir à ses citoyens que ces
droits sont respectés et ne sont pas
gérés et piétiné par des détails j'ai un
tout dernier mois jérémy assous
plusieurs plaintes ont donc été déposée
en france de quels moyens juridiques
dispose la france pour enquêter et ce
qu'il faudrait aussi ou bien plutôt
mener une procédure internationale
mais je pense qu'il va y avoir des
plaintes vont être déposées dans chaque
pays
alors c'est sûr que je me fait peu
d'illusions sur les actions qui vont
être mené au mexique en ce qui concerne
la france nous sommes quand même un des
pays les plus puissants du monde
et encore une fois quand le gouvernement
souhaite quelque chose ou veut quelque
chose qu'on a des moyens également on a
quand même des services secrets
des services de police qui ont quelques
compétences en matière informatique voix
pour rapporter la preuve de ce qu'il a
utilisés comment et pourquoi et avec
quelle autorisation on en tirera toutes
les conséquences
merci beaucoup d'avoir réagi sur notre
antenne jérémie assous vous rappelle que
vous êtes l'avocat de dominique simonnot
victimes de l'espionnage
via ce logiciel et gaz us